hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Astro creep now dig deep
deep deep deep back into the back
recesses of your mind where all the
suppressed memories of your childhood
Lyle irking in the darkness now if you
remember way way back in the yonder year
of 2015
you'll recall a game by the name of the
visitor and the visitor featured an
incredibly curious alien that wanted to
find out all about you but the only way
who knew how was to burrow deep deep
deep into your butthole a little bit and
then just maybe a little bit take over
your whole body and impersonate who you
are and cumulate your DNA into its
organic structure that's about the
grossest intro that I've ever done so
I'm really proud of that you'll also
remember a game by then [ __ ] so pissed
that's better that's what I wanted this
is the quality let's play you guys have
expected out of the markiplier channel
one of those days where everything goes
wrong well this ain't one of those days
that's my life or whatever it's not
gonna get any better just like this
let's play I already know it's going
down hills from the very GetGo from
timestamp 0 17 it started going downhill
trust me very much anyway enough of that
all that [ __ ] we got Astro creep
here made by the same guy who made
cannibal cafe and this one features and
the reason why I brought up all this
[ __ ] oh do possibilities exist
either we are alone in the universe who
we are not both are equally terrifying
but the reason I saw this who uses mouse
to click around the area to find guide
the alien through doors your goal is to
evolve to a stage that allows you to
create a nest and infest an entire space
station you will need to kill the humans
on board to evolve different
evolutionary forms unlock different
options ah and this is where it all
comes together because in the preview
for this game I saw an alien burrowing
up someone's butthole and boy howdy do I
want to get to that part of the game so
let's try to explore and meander Oh
surprise surprise I'm not dead did
someone literally just pick up this
floating corpse in the middle of space
and go like yeah sure I'll bring that on
my spaceship we've never even heard of
the
possibility of alien invaders and Body
Snatchers that couldn't possibly happen
so we got to go around here and try to
find a way to get our little alien but
oh it's a birthing baby oh listen to
it's adorable squeal of pain ooh it in
like that it's too hot for its sensitive
body oh that's better
that definitely cool we how's it going
there friend do you want an alien inside
of you there's some sex joke here but
I'm not gonna be able to see oh man I
did not know that that kind of kung fu
well let's give that another go then
shall we okay so we gotta incapacitate
him first before we're gonna be able to
do what we need to do lamby
good to know that things face was still
intact so that I could bust my way
through it okay so I can't immediately
dingdong dead dang ditch this guy so
either I go through the vents which I
can't cuz I can't unlock it so I'll go
through the door you'll never know I'm a
shadow in the night a little disgusting
slug like shadow in the night let's go
to the restroom because if I remember
something about burrowing inside
someone's butt hole it probably happens
in the restroom it's locked
never mind I'm gonna go away now good
thing they lock their bathrooms on these
space stations the future sure is
magical hello hi lady you look very very
very sad okay that's not gonna work
that's not gonna work that's not gonna
work that's not gonna work none of this
is gonna work what the hell I gotta do
well I'm gonna do why our wires be
curious why this thing opened and its
face exploded from within oh it's a
goose drop your pants
and so oh ah you have to click on the
corners okay so I'm an idiot not didn't
even obviously click on the giant yellow
things in front of my face but then
again I never do so no really need to
worry about that I'm I'm just incredibly
stupid okay right is right
I'm gonna go right to the restroom maybe
oh boy it's a puzzle Oh japón zl-- let's
try this one on its lonesome I bet it's
Oh No
boom wait boom whoa where do we go do
now we boo Boop oh that didn't work at
all wait a minute
something right about this okay boopity
boopity boopity boop then ah
and then Boop No hey we did it somehow
I'm very happy about that it wasn't
random chance at all that was schoo it's
time it's the moment we've all been
waiting for
I can't wait to cause this guy
intestinal - that's not what I meant I
didn't mean - wow that guy got angry I
mean if a slug dropped on me I guess
you'd be angry don't tell me I gotta go
all the way back to the beginning okay
good thank you you're nice oh ah almost
in there and that's not a good thing to
say so I know what to do it's the old
distraction method so have lip and yes
and then oh oh
shit's gonna go wrong for you quite
literally
holy [ __ ]
I can now spit venomous Barb's what was
going on with that guy's DNA that that
is what I absorbed I do not want to know
I don't need to know I don't want to go
anywhere except away from this horrible
horrible mess that I've created all
righty then let's go shall we
spit some poisonous Bob's let's close
that up no one needs to know about my
shame all right goodbye
little skinny [ __ ] all right now back
in here to the I'm sure he would have
heard that noise okay how about now
hey right in the crotch that's what you
get he's dead now can I use his body as
DNA can I use f Thompson's body oh yeah
could you stop that okay acidic
evolution vomit a highly corrosive acid
that can melt through all organic
material in most metals or telekinetic
evolution manipulate the will of organic
organisms move things with your mind
well that's fear that seems better I'm
gonna go that whew with the little head
on legs whoa why is he dancing he
doesn't need to dance
it's a tiny baby head on legs little
okay then on a skedaddle my way over
here hey do you want to be
telekinetically manipulated mm ooh
hello my brain my baby head is pulsating
with telekinetic end what are you doing
what are you doing oh I had a sneaking
suspicion to there that is a bouncy head
and as far as I know that's a closed
door over there
why
I didn't need to do that I didn't mean
to kill her I could have just clicked
the card and gone on through
whoo-hoo-hoo okay so I can't go through
there because I don't have anything
acidic which I guess is good huh Oh God
Oh your current ability is too weak to
penetrate the laser field you must
evolve to a higher form
oh really good thing this guy's so quick
on the draw with that laser field and
good thing there's a laser field to
begin with so I need to evolve to a
higher form huh look at their goodness
convenient body right behind this door
oh oh no that is dead space oh that is
dead space
ooh no no no no no no no no that is dead
space straight up that is one of the
rare deaths that Isaac Clark can go
through in dead space it's not often
found you know that long gangly dude
that falls apart into different things
if the head strangles you and you die
from that it will literally rip your
head off and then implant itself in your
body so in the most horrific deaths in
the game and that was what was amazing
about des base Hey hi it's me Lauren let
let me through look is me ah
your buddy ha ha it's your boo maybe all
right
[Music]
okay huh pick up this arm boobity
boobity boo nothing weird about that boy
these these oh these sad sacks didn't
stand a chance against me
oh I could have just I could have just
gone right through the vents and none
would Bend the wiser who would have
known that that would have been the
pacifist route through this game oh boy
oh did I win did I won oh I don't feel
like a winner but I guess I am
everyone's gonna die and I'm gonna reign
supreme on this parade
Gomi Gomi go and peeking of going where
the hell are we going ah is that Oh six
hours later huh is that when people
start to get suspicious about the
complete loss of crew on this ship I
don't want to know I don't know how I
was investigating that thing by myself
okay I'm gonna go the other route so
I'll be right back once I get to the
junction I was about to say
juxtaposition but that's the wrong word
for this situation
eat this ha ha what a loser
got killed by an alien and now we're
gonna be all acidic and [ __ ]
would you oh yeah so I'm so angry
Oh kids dead it goes across that's
adorable
hey no one gives back thing
I'm sorry sheesh I didn't want to mess
with me gee yeah oh yeah
easy this is the pacifist route oh boy
I'm sorry excuse me I was very rude of
me
plus all the murder that I'm not doing
every yeah oh no I do have to murder him
oh no he won't know what's gonna happen
oh man this poor guy no matter what
happens zoom he just gets disintegrated
can I steal you who knew so what happens
when I go back and see the lady is she
gonna freak out because now I'm oh it's
back up dang it that was my one
opportunity to go through there oh no I
know I don't think there was an arrow
there anyway so I couldn't gone back
that's why I went left first anyway so
that wasn't even an option so I
shouldn't be too worried about that so
so money just jump jump in my way to
victory no I ain't no one gonna bother
me
oh these a little caracal water yes yes
this looks like excellent closet to
masturbate furiously
for six straight hours and then my goal
has been accomplished the entire world
is infested good thing I got a lower
body cuz that was all that I needed okay
so we are done we're all done here
woo boy that was horrifying but either
way that is a stroke reap and oddly
enough a lot of fun like that morbid
curiosity a little bit of this type of
game is kind of fun to see so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye